Now we're going to drill
down into the details and
make many of the notions we've
been talking about more precise.
First, we need to define running time.
We'll let M be a Turing machine.
Single tape, multi tape, random access,
the definition works for
all of them and
we assume that it halts on all inputs.
The running time then is a function
over the natural numbers where F of N is
the largest number of steps taken by a
machine for an input string length of n.
We can extend this definition to
machines that don't halt as well,
by making their runtime infinite.
We're always considering
the worst case here.
Let's illustrate this
idea with an example.
Consider this single tape machine
that takes in a binary input.
And tests whether
the input contains a 1.
On encountering a 0,
it simply loops back into this q0
state and moves the head to the right.
When it encounters a 1,
it accepts and halts immediately and
if it encounters the blank symbol,
indicating the end of the input without
ever having encountered a 1, it rejects.
Let's figure out the running time for
a string of length 2.
We need to consider all
possible strings of length 2.
So we'll make a table like this and
count the number of steps.
The largest number of steps is 3.
We had to read the 0,
the 0 and the blank after it.
And so,
that then is the overall running time.
F(2) = 3.